let's be the gentlemen behind the very
attractive boy
please welcome to comic-con Benedict
Cumberbatch everybody you exist you only
never get to see this normally I've
never seen this before man hello first
Comic Con Benedict the first time you've
been here oh yeah I think I think you'll
have a nice time many people are happy
that you're here
oh well many many of me are happy to
about the chap they Wolfie chap that you
play in the film no I can't it's
classified
he's either sort of all-action wolf
basically and he he heads up this team
called the north wind which looks after
animal welfare wherever it needs looking
after
and he knows about this plot and he's
after Octavius brine and so constipating
wins to try and get as much information
out of them as possible yeah yeah he
doesn't it's not like an extraordinary
rendition or anything it's it's a little
bit more hospitable than that and he he
kind of brings him into north wind and
tries to to get information so that he
can take his team to do the professional
work for them and he really
underestimates what they're capable of
and overestimates what he's capable of
and you it you enjoy because you you
like John you've been known to do other
work involving your entire body in the
acting as well you enjoy the you enjoy
the animation you enjoy the enjoy the
experience I like to use my body yeah
yeah no I do I mean it's a it's very
weird on that level because you are
you're in isolation the first time I met
John was yesterday
and I got to ask him this legend of
acting this extraordinary brilliant man
the first question I got John was
something like so what was it like
playing an evil octopus but the point is
that you know we've never been in a room
together right I think we were both sold
the job on that front so Jefferies got
something to answer for yeah because
when I Jeffrey asked me to do the Dragon
movie and then after I said yes then he
I had to kind of do a tapes where he
checked that I was okay did you have to
go through that no you didn't know he
didn't mr. Cumberbatch mr. Malcolm oh
sure come this way no no it seems fair I
suppose in a way they didn't ask you to
host this new so that you all work
together all the time that you three
directors work with each actor at a time
or do you split up and you can have you
know head them off for the past we try
to work together when we can
right we're heads we get in the room the
better but you know the main thing is to
get these guys in the room and let them
just have fun with it so there's an
awful lot of improvisation that goes on
an awful lot of back and forth and ideas
and it's what the process allows us to
do is kind of be a free-form do you like
do you like having actors more to them
one at a time I mean I think there might
be quite a power play and just splitting
the actors up so that they don't kind of
go in because you know where actors are
like they go into the Tea Room and they
start having ideas and then they come
back to you and talk to you about things
because there's no that's why you do it
that's the secret you discovered oh yeah
oh do you like having them together does
it help um we it's honestly it's down to
schedule right 90% of the time it's
almost impossible to get the two people
especially at this caliber in the same
room at the same is the implication
there that it would be fine if it was me
because that's what I'm gaining no and
I'm not saying that I'm three all the
time yeah there any way that no did you
do the scratch voices that was that the
thing you did the scratch voice and then
you became the really yeah pretty much
the scratch voice you know but I'd love
to have twenty five bags of Cheetos and
work with been addictive
if he was game announcement coming up
about an app dare ministration they're
launched a dream arts and wanting an app
this morning called the surveillance app
it does a couple of things first the
Penguins apparently that's the idea of
the Penguins are providing security at
comic-con this year you can listen live
to the conversation on walkie-talkies
which is a form of phone okay I think
the only part I'm having trouble with
the idea that comic-con would mean
security what are you you're nice all
right the for the ultimate penguin photo
bomb app is incredibly easy to use with
this app you can make a Penguins photo
bomb any photo you have or take here are
some examples do we have some examples
of
[Applause]
huh did you or the cat you are the cat
all right oh right okay um it's very
easy to do apparently I'm sorry for this
informational it was a it's just
something I do spontaneously from time
to time step one is what you download
the app from iTunes or Google Play or
whatever illegal method you nerdz know
about that they don't and they what you
do is use the app to take a photo
apparently we have pulled a person from
the audience oh of the Q&A line is it
started the Q&A line has it started
where is it it hasn't started yet oh
it's over there alright we're going to
pull someone out of the Q&A line and
show you how easy it is to use oh yes hi
hi guy from the Q&A line what's your
name sir
and he was Mike hey Mike all right we'll
take a photo of you once you've taken
the photograph well done Mike and
congratulations
you'll never sleep again what we'll do
is now we we add the pen you take the
photo and you add the Penguins
apparently can you do that with the app
has that been done has anyone done that
or not I think I just the right once you
think before you add the photobombing
Penguins in the final step you can
decide to send the photo to the
Northwind using hashtag penguin
protection which is nothing to do with
prophylactics
I thank you those of you that wanted me
to be a little bit smarter this morning
or you can send that photo to dave dave
the octopus of course using hashtag
penguins for Dave all right and every
two weeks you can win prizes from the
north wind or from david i think i
dreamworks give you your own movie i
think that's what they gave you or if
you're an actor you get to be in the
movie without Jeffrey checking you out
all right cast continues discussion
spontaneously with cast members taking
questions from the audience all right
this is the the big Comic Con thing of
course we take questions from the
audience the panel here are available to
your questions we are set up over here
before we begin one last warning any
questions about Sherlock Comic Con is
canceled or perhaps it's fine I don't
know all right do we have a first
question please identify yourself
my name is William I just want to say
thank you John and Benedict for coming
to San Diego thank you Benedict my
friend would absolutely faint to ask you
directly so that's why I'm here okay we
just want to know for Penguins of
Madagascar another voiceover roles
what's the process that you go through
to convey so much emotion into the movie
from the cold sound booth it's sheer
hell you have to go undercover for a
long time I worked in Yellowstone Park
as a wolf for a while I was accepted
into the bat quite quickly got a bit
hairy when no pun intended when I became
the alpha male that's happened of about
three weeks and then about a month into
it I realized that two of the other
wolves were Christian Bale and Daniel
day-lewis so
yeah we it was fun out there the hardest
thing is getting our wolf actually you
know going to the bathroom it's that's a
new education and eating habits are a
little bit awkward and don't put any
kidneys in front of me but apart from
that it's great fun now I mean in all
seriously you know you do you throw
yourself around a little bit it's not
like motion-capture it's not like the
sort of full-body experience that that
is but yeah you there are only certain
things you can actually make a voice to
do without moving so at times I was
imagining things hitting me whilst
holding onto a plane
[Music]
and yeah that's that just takes you
asking about and being a bit of a Wally
and having home inhibitions whatsoever
which I paid to have none of but no I
did I enjoyed it I enjoyed it it's great
fun thank you a question tell you that
the first 10 people in line are going to
receive e who are asking questions are
receiving a secret skipper thumb drive
as some of the material we've seen today
has been loaded onto those thumb drives
and Dreamworks would like you to start
pushing it out for them Oh perhaps that
was just the secrets forget I said that
all right your next question please
hello hi what's your name
my name is Jada where you from I'm
originally from Georgia of Atlanteans
okay not the whole thing just now
[Applause]
surprisingly okay um what is the thing
that attracted you most to classifies
character to make you want to bring this
character life to work with the Penguins
really I mean you know the whole kind of
bond pastiche that he is this this guy
who's got all the professionalism he's
got all the tools he's got he's got a
team and he's got this kind of slick
operation and yet he's it's it's
sometimes only go skin deep so he's
completely
there's a nice vulnerability to him and
he has to learn he has to learn to
abandon planning and embrace just
running at the problem rather like the
Penguins do and I like that I don't like
the idea of unpacking a spy and trying
to make them a little bit more human if
that makes any sense when you're playing
a wolf but yeah it was it was that
really and also just the pedigree of you
know the studio's work they make me
laugh they make the kids that I've seen
the films with laughs so I thought I'd
try and give it a go myself and I've
never done this kind of work I've never
done a narration for an animation before
I mean a voice for an animation before
so all of that and this one here and I
heard about his casting and that got me
very excited and the Penguins themselves
I mean they're just winning winning
characters so yeah we have someone
else's life hi um I'm Madeline
Greenblatt I'm from Texas
okay and I teach thanks I teach third
grade and all of my kids love all the
masks our movies all of books and
everything and it imposes their lives
and I want to know what characters books
as a child did that for you and how you
bring it - straight for the whole panel
see right so well who began this process
who began the Penguins of Madagascar I
guess you were right there at the
beginning right now I'd like Benedict to
answer this crap we'll get to Emile gets
what influenced you as a child it's a
fair question what did what made you
laugh in your head
why was born in the 60s so I think you
know me all right yeah the books of the
sixties right so what TV shows that you
watch well I think you know Star Trek
well there's a risk at comic-con I think
there's always these groups I think you
know you know from from SWAT to the
a-team you know Star Trek you know the
Penguins are a bit of an amalgam of all
these shows and they took the best of
international characters brought them
together into a kind of a underdog group
that saw nothing as impossible
and that's really who the Penguins are
and they they are just a combination of
all these whether it be you know Stalag
17 or the Dirty Dozen or you know Spock
and Kirk it's it's it's the trying to
get the best of all these characters
that come together and what's great
about the Penguins there are these huge
personalities in a tiny package and and
that's that's the inspiration what about
what about you John I imagine you're
slightly off the beaten track in the
terms of a childhood influence I I
actually had quite eclectic tastes and I
liked anything a huge number of things
but only if they starred Hayley Mills
never disappoint me John never and I
also was a huge fan of Leave It to
Beaver so those were my two big
culturally now it makes perfect sense
Benedict what about you what kind of let
your torch when you were a kid for
entertainment The Hobbit actually did
and that's not really yeah that was the
first book my dad ever read to me so
that rack that was in my head as an
imaginary space when I was a kid going
to sleep at night I don't know how
healthy that is but it was I turned out
a write and I I that was a wonderful
inference and spawn my interests in the
written word having the power to create
those imaginary worlds beyond that
television wise I all sorts of things I
mean I was a kid of the 80 so you know
the 18 werewolf from animal all those
kind of Knight Rider and and then gentle
Ben to because I shared the name egotist
at a young age it was yeah it's a feral
makes you but yes I grew up with two
actors so stories abound it probably
stories adult stories I shouldn't be
hearing it shouldn't have been hearing
at the age I heard them but also you
know they were very good at creating
worlds and characters right yeah imagine
in my mind yes thank you very much what
a lovely question thank you lady from
Texas next lady
all right what's your name hi I'm
Marissa um firstly I want to say hi
Craig my dad and I watch your show every
night total I love you um and then okay
I'm gonna try not to cry
Benedict you're yes I'll try not to cry
too well I'll try it together
yeah so I'm studying media and London
right now and my question was you know
you said you're new to voice acting and
I was wondering what new techniques you
needed to bring to the table versus like
stage or screen acting um I mean I've
done a bit of radio so that's probably
the most helpful medium to cabin
pressure
[Applause]
thank you
and so book reads and and that's very
hard actually the hardest thing the most
useful thing is to do an adaptation of a
book because you are the book you're the
you're the narrative voice but you also
all the individual characterizations so
that you really do get that eager trip
of playing all the parts and with that
you have to imagine a lot of the
scenarios and listen this is a great
team of writers and directors and
artists who can lead you through step by
step to give you a very firm idea of how
to contextualise any moment but you
still have to take a little leap
yourself to get there but with it's not
like doing a book read that's the
hardest thing I'd say I never I have
ever done vocally so with their help
their scripts and their genius it's kind
of a walk in the park and you just get
to end up improvisation is very
important so being able to be free with
an idea push an idea go too far come
back do the full circle thing you do in
rehearsals you know good idea at the
beginning awful ideas for the rest of it
coming back to the same good idea or
alright idea that that you know that
process is really important not not to
be frightened of experimenting why are
you studying media Saint Mary's
University in Twickenham
oh nice Bo the well yeah very good how's
it going
really really good really really really
good
there's yeah well the show looks you do
is not far from there did you know oh
god to mention show up sorry how'd you
cut my mouth with other actors did you
know which I mean I would I was really
gutted about that because I was really
looking forward to working with the
Penguins and John and and my team I've
not met a single one of my team so
that's it's really bizarre and that's
almost the hardest thing you don't have
the usual camaraderie which you do in
most other mediums but I did I didn't I
didn't really for um for smoke either
because I was I was in a room I was
doing motion caption Martin was in
England and would have been the size of
a fleck of dust on the carpet if he had
been there would have been pretty
difficult to imagine him as that and and
so I had a great actor reading off lines
like I did every single session with
recording this yeah you don't build that
chemistry though right I think you're
not yeah to improvising against
brilliant writers in the studio
somewhere listening of watching and that
these are my two first audience all of
our first audience and if you make them
laugh right you know you're you're
somewhere in the right ballpark and they
just keep on going with it do you ever
feel slightly because the fact that
these guys have written the script and
they really want you to see their words
but you really want to see other words
which you think may possibly be better
I always read lines first no no of
course but I think that you know I feel
that when because I've done the same
type of thing and when you work with
people who have written the script I I
sometimes feel a little awkward about
you know futzing with it when you know
they've they've been doing it when it
when it's just a director who didn't
write it I'm like oh hell let's have a
go at this you know and yeah I'm being a
theater originating theater I yeah the
Texas you after one of the sayings
that's always very respectful of that
and then I will go into they provide
John what do you what do you feel about
this well also growing up in the theater
you really didn't touch
texts and I didn't start doing it at all
in movies meaning making any changes to
the text until finally I realized at a
certain point in time when I was asked
to do a project I would say yes that's
very nice but on and it's a very nice
structure and it's a fantastic idea and
none of the characters in any way
exhibit any kind of human behavior
that's or dialogue that's at all
recognizable is there any plan afoot to
change that that fact on the ground and
they would always say yeah yeah we're
doing yeah there's a bastard and then
eventually I just started doing it
myself but with this one it's quite
complicated because they're actually
very happy for any or anything you want
to throw out there but of course we
don't actually know what it's going to
be right so that makes improvisation
quite complicated right it has to be
within certain parameters yeah yes you
really don't know if you knew okay we're
gonna be skyping each other and I'm too
stupid to Skype my character and I in
fact I'm so stupid I can't even find my
reading glasses then then I might be
able to say something but we we in
general don't know those things no and
your forehead advising with someone else
you're not gay right and you know rule
of not putting a block up and continuing
the conversation you and that I wonder
if they improvised ten years over and
the animation process that if you have
an idea for a scene and you're working
with an actor and an actor has an idea
or something occurs organically when
you're in the process will that change
the way you approach the scene visualize
sure absolutely I mean these guys were
throwing out lots of fantastic stuff and
oftentimes the script is the starting
point right and then you work the scene
and work the scene and work the scene
and then you get this fantastic gold
that comes out of it which is you get
the the substance of the scene but not
in the way that was originally written
but it's fantastic it's much better
brain you know also text what text I
don't know if you'd feel this way but a
text is a very odd thing we I've done I
think every phrase in this including
every word at least a hundred yes if not
a thousand but often with text even if
it's just a word Oh Dave you never
really get to the bottom up so a lot of
actors before wanting to move on and
saying hey I did this twice um sorry I
covered every possible option I said
Dave twice okay but a lot of actors
really want to go through also every
possible way of doing it and sometimes
one of those ways is actually preferable
right right yeah or more correct and
that's another reason why although I
don't necessarily not trying to say
we're we're extremely reticent to try
and add something it's just that that
can be more complicated than just making
a clever phrase right because we may not
have gotten to the bottom of what's
already on the page yes oh thank you for
letting me
lady with a sign that says 15 minutes on
it yes thank you John
next question please hello hello hey
what's your name my name is Lynn I'm
from China and I do eat octopus just if
you're wondering but not when there are
our pets or when there are our friends
or both you like more or less us ready
answer the question so I will come over
that the new question wishes for benefit
and for join so what do you think it's a
major difference away you are performing
in a adults movie like ready to or or
above and with like pg-13 or PG movies
gentlemen yonder what's the difference
when you're in adult movies as opposed
[Laughter]
[Applause]
Kiro hearst grow up one is happier in
adult even a consideration or you just
exist within the world that's it I I
don't really think about the ratings I
don't understand them very well either
you know you can chop someone's head off
all of their extremities make a
milkshake and people go it's it's good
it's good but if you show part of
someone's thigh or upper arm we can have
that other um it's very strict in San
Diego Benedict very very scared of the
arm I'm actually flaunting the law yes
do we have another question I do yes
hello sir and my name is David Bledsoe
from Tampa Florida I David and I love
the footage from the movie but my friend
and I noticed that there weren't any
raccoons in the movie and was wondering
if you were planning to put raccoons or
other animals in the movie or maybe in
sequels like raccoons of Madagascar or
something of that nature
any raccoon plans gentlemen well you
know we hadn't thought of right that's a
great idea yeah we'll get right on it
right now yeah if you if you head to the
site here Jeffrey Katzenberg we'll take
your idea I'd pay you a million dollars
for
you might also take a look at over the
hedge I think there's a raccoon in there
oh yeah the raccoon in it yeah hello
young lady
hi what's your name I'm Heidi I'm also
from Florida Oh welcome and I'm with the
three patch podcast and we have a
question mostly for Benedict mm-hmm
basically someone sort of asked it or
you sort of answered it before but
what's the different process for you in
working on something animated like this
versus a radio show where you not only
have your co-workers with you but also
an audience that's kind of a I'm strong
you think about what we've kind of
covered I kind of yeah I hate said I
kind of have um yeah yeah I mean sorry I
think mr. Cumberbatch was very erudite
and and covered it quite expertly before
so um you know poco doing or something
else yeah you could add something else
yeah ask what my shoe size is what do
you see about sneaking a share lock
questions Nika - air lock question
sorry they're officially telling me I'm
not allowed allowed to ask about
Sherlock so I'll just say what's your
experience going sorry
will you come back for Sherlock next
year yeah I I see what you mean by come
back here I thought you may come back as
Sherlock I possibly possibly possibly
I'd love to but it's that's kinda hard
of her to follow
oh my name is Jonathan and I'm from
Phoenix hi John then Tom I don't know if
you remember me from here's back wait
hold up the wristband again yeah what's
going on you guys got a past what
happened just the con oh yeah what
happens in the cons things in the gum
all right good to see you Jonathan
all right hey all right I'm gonna give
John and Benedict a break and direct
this question to Simon Eric and Tom okay
to park Weston up when he started
developing the movie what was it a
conscious decision to kind of build new
characters as opposed to pulling
characters from the TV show well for
sports all right and because when I
answer two questions to make yeah yeah
no is the liberation that we wanted to
take the Penguins out of their comfort
zone and take him worldwide and put on a
world globe-trotting adventure and the
new characters along the way this also
is in a sense a sequel to Madagascar 3
it exists in the world of the films and
not in the world of the TV show which
was kind of an alternate reality where
Julian was that the zoo and and so this
this kind of maintains that continuum
from the feature films but then from
there Simon the sand we wanted to pull
penguins out make them the stars and put
them into some place that should
challenge them and you know get them out
of their comfort zone a little bit and
so we got Benedict's character and
John's character to really put on the
pressure shake it up a little yeah
actually I think that answered the
second question so alright good well if
I thank you for that question we have
only time for one more question so what
one more question please and that that
would be a hello young lady what's your
name hi I'm Katherine I'm from Fort
Myers Florida hi there my question is
for John and for Benedict mm-hmm you've
both played villains if you had your
choice what classic comic book hero
would you like to play we didn't ask for
suggestions from the flower hey Lois
Lane nurse normal wait for it
penny dropped oh yeah as a joke on
Doctor Strange um I I don't know Batman
I guess in the died it's me I'm afraid
that's that's all we have time for from
floor so before we conclude I have a
special treat for you apparently first
of all please thank the cast and
filmmakers
with Maya benedict cumberbatch good
Malkovich cinemagraph Eric Darnell Simon
J Smith thank you and yes you can if you
want if you go then hope you go thank
you
you